A Sunday morning in my life as a young Christian wife.
Jacob and I don't have children yet,
so Sunday mornings are usually pretty low key and very chill.
And this morning was one of those days.
Except for a little mess that happened that you'll see in just a bit.
Here's Jacob telling me, NFL drama,
but he's like, does he work for the NFL?
He works for, uh,
ESPN.
Yikes. My husband is not a big sports guy.
It's been really fun to learn how football works
together with his fantasy team,
and I appreciate hearing all the little updates.
And then this is where everything changed in my morning.
I spilled my matcha all over my coffee table,
and Jacob was so quick to come to my rescue.
We started putting up all of our Christmas decor last night,
and we did not finish, so I do feel a little behind in that.
But that's okay. We can.
We can get it done tonight.
It's not that big of a deal.
On Sunday mornings,
I like my makeup and skincare to be very quick and easy,
and my tallow based skincare is the perfect base for.
For this. And it's buildable so I can put makeup on top of it.
And my skin looks so smooth and soft,
and I've really feel it throughout the day.
Love fierce nature.
Shout out to them. This morning
we're visiting my sister's church
because she's starting a new small group.
At her church, and I'm very excited to go and support her in that.
It's crazy how our lives have changed so much in just four short years.
But the Lord is so faithful and has done so many good things,
and I know he will continue to do so. Have a great Sunday.